ladies and gentlemen of the Romanian
national anthem I did not ask you to
stand because I didn't play it as a
symbol of Romanian national identity
rather to celebrate the end of the Cold
War which occurred about the time that
you were born before that no one came to
MIT from Eastern Europe but since that
time we've been blessed by having in our
midst
Lithuanians Estonians poles Czechs
Slovaks Bulgarians
Romanians slovenians Serbs and all sorts
of people from regions of the world
formally excluded to us believe me you
are all welcome in our house almost all
that is to say because you may recall
that Romania is the traditional home of
vampires and since the end of the Cold
War vampires have had new vectors for
emerging from their traditional places
and penetrating into the world at large
you may have a vampire in your suite or
on your floor and it is important to
know how to to recognize them and take
the necessary precautions so if you have
a this concern I would expect that the
first thing you would do would be to
look at some data concerning the
characteristics of vampires
so there's a little database of samples
of individuals who have been determined
to be vampires and not vampires
and our task today and what you'll
understand how to do by the end of the
hour is to use data like this to build a
recognition mechanism that would help
you to identify whether someone is a
vampire or an ordinary person so this is
a little different from the kind of
problem we worked with with neural nets
right so what's what's the most
conspicuous difference between this data
set and anything you could think to work
on with that I say no nearest neighbors
nearest neighbors which we studied last
time Katie do you have any thoughts
about why it would be difficult to use
nearest neighbors with data like this
other way the question mark is there
because this is MIT and a lot of people
are completely nocturnal so you can't
tell whether they cast a shadow or not
we want to take that into account so
what's different about this from the
electrical cover data set
to you the nearest neighbor technique to
identify vampires with this data get so
obvious you overlook license yes Juana
this is not a numerical data this is the
bar so we're not saying your shadow is
point seven you either cast a shadow
don't cast a shadow or we can't tell
it's a symbolic result so problem number
one that we have to face with data this
kind is that it's not numeric and there
are other characteristics as well for
example it's not clear that all of these
characteristics actually matter
so some characteristics don't matter
and a corollary to that is that some
characteristics do matter but they only
matter part of the time and finally
there's the matter of cost some of these
tests may be more expensive to perform
than others for example if you wanted to
determine whether someone cast a shadow
you'd have to go to the trouble of
getting up during daylight that might be
an expensive operation for you you'd
have to go find some garlic and ask them
to eat it that might be expensive so
some of these tests might be expensive
relative to other tests but once you
realize that we are talking in terms of
tests and not a vector of real values
then what you do is clear you build
yourself a little tree of tests
so who knows how this problem will turn
out but you can imagine a situation
where you have one test up here which
might have three outcomes and one of
those outcomes might require one but
only one of those outcomes might require
you to form another test and only when
you've created a tree of tests that look
like this are you finished
so given this set of tests and a set of
samples the question becomes how do you
arrange the tests in a tree like that so
as to do the identification that you
want to do so since we're talking about
identification it's not surprising that
this kind of tree is called an
identification tree and there's a
tendency and I may slip into it myself
to call this a decision tree but a
decision tree is a label for something
else this is an identification tree and
the task is to create a good one so what
is a good one versus a not-so-good one
what characteristic would you like for a
decision tree for an identification tree
to have if you're going to call it a
good identification tree what do you
think Krishna what would be a good
characteristic
yeah he said minimum number of levels
what's another way you can say what a
good one is each test cost something
right so what's another way of thinking
about what a good tree would look like
the minimum cost and if they all have
the same cost that is the minimum number
of tests so overall what you like is a
small tree rather than a big one so you
might be able to take your sample data
and divide it up so that at the bottom
of the tree at the leaves all the sets
that are produced by the test are are
uniform homogeneous well you like that
tree to be the simplest possible tree
you can find not so big complicated one
that also divides up all the data into
uniform subsets by uniform subsets you
know at the bottom of the tree like have
all have all the vampires together and
all the non vampires together alright so
you like a small tree so why not just go
all the way and do British Museum and
calculate all possible trees well you
can do that but it's one of those NP
problems and as you know NP problems
suck in general and and so you don't
want to do that you want to have some
kind of heuristic mechanism for building
a small tree and we want a small tree
because what do we want a small trial
because of the cost there's another more
important reason why we want a small
tree let me give you a hint it's Occam's
razor the simplest explanation is often
the best explanation so if you have a
big complicated explanation that's
probably probably less good than a
simple small explanation Occam's razor
spelled so many ways it doesn't matter
how I spell it and that's good because I
can't spell so I don't know how we going
to go about finding the best possible
arrangement of those four tests
and a tree like that well step one will
be to see what each test does with the
data and by the way before I go a step
further you know and I know that this is
a sample data set that's very small
suitable for classroom manipulation
you've never bet your life on a data set
this small we use it only for classroom
illustration but imagine that these rows
are multiplied by 10 so instead of 80
Sam instead of 8 samples you've got 80
then you might begin to believe the
results that are produced so I'm just
going to pretend that each one of those
represents 10 other samples that I
haven't bothered to show but we can't
work with this one in the classroom
because it's pretty small and we can say
well what is the shadow test do well the
shadow test divides the sample
population into three groups there's the
I don't know group of people who are
nocturnal there are the people who do
cast the shadow the yes people and the
people who do not cast a shadow the know
people so if I look at those rows up
there and see which ones are vampires it
looks to me that if they do not cast a
shadow there's no shadow cast there's
only one it doesn't cast a shadow and
that is a vampire so that's a plus over
there
vampire now if we look at the ones who
who do cast a shadow all of those are
not vampires they're all okay and now
there are eight three are vampires so
that means that two of these must be
vampires and I've got three four five
six so far so there must be two left so
that's the way the shadow test divides
up the data now let's do garlic vampires
traditionally a don't eat garlic I don't
know why so we look at the garlic test
and we see that all the noes are only
three yeses and they're all and they all
produce a no answer something if
somebody eats garlic they're not
vampires that means the three vampires
must be over here and they're two left
so that's what the garlic test does see
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to look at all these tests to see which
one would like best on our basis how it
divides up the data so now we've got I
don't know complexion and there are
three choices for this you can have an
average complexion but a lot of vampires
in my experience are rather pale so pale
is a possibility and then the other
option is that just after gorging
themselves with blood they tend to get a
little red in the face so we'll have it
ready over here once again we have to go
back to our data set to see how this
test device things up so there are three
red E's and one's a no one's a no and
one's a yes so - nose and a yes - nose
nes now we can try it for pale
complexion people there are only two of
those a no and a No
that must mean that there are two pluses
over here because there are three
vampires all together
two four six seven eight nine oh eight
sorry eight only eight just one more to
go and that's the accent historically
vampires go to great lengths to perfect
their accent and not betray their
origins but nevertheless we can expect
that if they've just arrived if they're
just in from Transylvania part of
Romania they may still have an accent so
there's a normal as to some still have a
heavy accent and some persistent having
odd accident so let's see accent four of
them right at the top have no accent to
nose and EES heavy accent three of those
a yes and two nose that means we must
have a plus here three six plus and a
minus so we can look at this at this
data and say well what it'd be the best
test to use and the best has to use
would surely be the one that produces
produces subsets or producing sets here
at the bottom of the branches that
correspond to the outcomes of the test
we're looking for a test that produces
homogeneous groups so just for the sake
of illustration I'm going to suppose
that we're going to judge the quality of
a test by how many sample individuals it
puts into a homogeneous set so we want
to we want what ideally would like a
test that would put all the vampires in
one group and all the ordinary people in
another group right off the bat but
there are no such tests but we can't add
up the number of sample individuals who
are put into at least homogeneous sets
so when we do that this guy has three in
a homogeneous set here a fourth but
these are not in a homogeneous set so
the overall score for this guy will be
for this one
well not quite as good it only puts
three individuals in homogeneous set
this one here two individuals into a
homogeneous set everybody else is all
mixed up with some other kind of person
and over here how many people are how
many samples are homogeneous set zero so
on the basis of this analysis you would
conclude that the ordering of the test
with respect to their quality is left to
right so the best test must be the
shadow test so let's pick the shadow
test first see what we can do with that
if we pick the shadow test first and we
have this arrangement we have question
mark and we have yes cast a shadow and
no doesn't we have three minuses here I
have a plus here and unfortunately over
here we have plus plus minus minus so we
need another test to divide that group
up yes
well if I look at the data and I see who
we have a question is what about that
shadow test if you look at the shadow
test you say well there are four
question marks and if we look at see
what kind of people belong to those four
question marks there are two vampires
and two non vampires
that's why there's two pluses and two
minuses oh yeah no I'm scoring this the
question is how do I get this number for
it's not have nothing to do with this
because it's a mixed set in fact I've
got three guys in a homogeneous set here
and one guy in the homogeneous set here
I'm just adding them up so very simple
classroom illustration wouldn't work in
practice yes the question is how do I
adjust this for larger data sets you're
one step ahead okay thank you so I trust
me I'll be dealing with large data sets
in a moment I just want to get get the
idea across and I don't want it there to
be any thought that the method we use
for larger data sets kind of a magic
about it okay so we're off and running
and now we have to pick a test that will
divide those four guys up so we're going
to work this a little harder and repeat
the analysis we did there but at least
it'll be simpler because now we're only
considering four samples not eight just
the four samples that we still have to
divide up that have come down that left
branch so we have the shadow test it has
three outcomes we have the complete test
it has two outcomes yes and no we have
the complexion test there's three
outcomes average pale and ruddy and we
have finally the accent test and that
comes out to be either normal heavy or
odd and now it's a little awkward to
figure out what the results are for
the data set has shown so let me just
strike out the ones that were no longer
concerned with and limit our analysis to
the samples for which the outcome of the
shadow test is a question mark this is
exactly the four people we still need to
separate all right so switching colors
keeping the color the same we actually
don't want to do the shadow test anymore
right because we've already done that so
you know there's no point doing that
again we don't have to look at that it's
already done all the division of data
that it can so the garlic chest well
let's see garlic - yes is - knows the S
is produced nose and the nose produce
yeses so if the person does eat garlic
they're okay and if they don't eat
garlic bad news they're vampires
well looks like pretty good test but
just for the sake of working it all out
let's try the others complexion -
readies a yes and a no one pale and
that's a no one pale and that's a no and
we must have one average and sure enough
that's a yes now we can do accent the
one on the far right look at how that
measures up against the the people who
are still under consideration as samples
accent let's see two nuns a yes and a no
too heavy we're one heavy no heavy -
odds yes that I know all right so now we
can do the same thing we did before and
just say for sake of classroom
illustration how many individuals are
put into homogeneous sets and here we
have four and here we have two and here
we have zero so plainly the Garlic test
is the test of choice so we go back over
here and we've
completed the work that we needed to do
so that's a garlic test and that
produces two pluses let's see each
garlic yes
eats garlic no I guess the pluses go
over here like so and these are the two
ordinary people and we're done with our
task and now you can quickly run off and
put this into your PD PDA and forever be
protected as possibility one of those
vampires got out and that flood of
people came in from Europe except what
do we do with a large data set
well trouble is a large data sets not
lutely produce put any no tests at the
beginning of a large data sets likely to
do the to the job for any it'll matter
if you have a large data set no test is
likely to put together any homogeneous
set right off so you never get started
everything would be zero every test
would say aw doesn't put any anybody
into homogeneous sets so you're screwed
you need some other way you have some
other you need some other more
sophisticated way of measuring how
disordered this data is or how
disordered these sets are that you find
at the bottom of the tree branches
that's what you need a way of measuring
disorder of these tests of these sets
that you find at the bottom of these
branches so you can find a kind of
overall quality to the test based on
your measurement of disorder
now the first heuristic of a good life
is when you have a problem to solve as
somebody who knows the answer it's the
least amount of work it's not even as
hard as going to Google so who would you
ask about measures ways of measuring
disorder and sets there are two possible
answers
Oh who but you what find the interview
studies entropy what kind of classes
physics thermodynamics the
thermodynamics is are good at measuring
disorder because that's what they're
whenever it's all about entropy
increasing over time loss or so there's
another answer there's another equally
good answer
statisticians perhaps but it's not the
best second best answer it's actually
not even the best answer that's the best
answer which would Leonardo has got his
finger on it the information theorists
are pretty good at measuring disorder
because that's what information is all
about - so we might as well borrow a
mechanism for measuring the disorder of
a set from those information theory guys
so what we're going to do is exactly
that let's put it over here so we'll
have a kind of handy when we want to try
to measure those things what they say is
the Gospel according to the information
theorists is that the disordered d of
some set is equal to now let's suppose
that this is a set of a binary values so
we have positives and we have negatives
pluses and minuses but pluses they don't
go very well an algebraic equation
because it might be confused with adding
so I'm going to say P and P and N and
then they'll be the total which is P
plus n well I got two choices positive
and negative so the disorder of a set
according to those guys is equal to
minus the number of positives over the
total number times the log to the base 2
of the positives over the total minus
the negatives over the total times the
log two of the negatives over the total
those negatives will worrisome because
you think well maybe this thing can go
negative but that's not going to be true
right because these ratios are all less
than one and the logarithm is something
that's less than one is negative so
we're okay so that's a lovely way of
measuring disorder and maybe we ought to
draw a graph of what that curve looks
like and what we're going to graph it
against is the ratio of positives to the
total number so that's going to be an
axis where we go from zero to one so I
don't know let's just find a couple of
useful values by the way pays to pay
attention to these curves because if you
pay attention to stuff you can work the
quiz questions on this very rapidly
otherwise you you know we see people
getting out their calculators and
quickly becoming both lost and screwed
okay so let's see let's suppose that the
number of positives is equal to the
number of negatives so we've got a
completely mixed up set it has no bias
in either direction so in that case if P
of T P over T is equal to one-half then
this is equal to minus 1/2 times the
logarithm of 1/2 and I guess since
they're both the same we can multiply by
2 and what's that value 9 I thought what
does that calculate out
- like a facade well with a minus sign
you just turn it arguing upside down so
it's law - so let's log to base the
logarithm of base 2 of 2 1 so this whole
thing this whole thing is 1 so Matassa
enter soft voice says well let's see 2
times 1/2 that cancels out the - that
flips the argument so it's log to the
base 2 of 1 of 2 and that's 1 so this
whole thing it works out you work out
the algebra gives you 1 so that's cool
so right here in the middle where
they're equal now we get a value of 1
next thing we need to do is let's
calculate - what happens if P over T is
equal to 1
now does it say everything is a positive
any guesses maybe 10 20 minus 15 let's
work it out so that would be if P of T
equal P over T equals 1 that would be
minus 1 times the log to the base 2 of 1
what's that at zero oh yeah because 2
raised to the 1 is 0 2 raised to the 0
is 1 so this part is 0 now what about
this other part we have - if P
everything's apenas nothing's in N so we
got zero and we can quit already
well not quite we ought to work it out
log to the base 2 of 0 what's that whoo
- infinity o 0 times minus infinity is
what I didn't get that when I was in
high school finally 1801 makes a
difference right finally what's the
answer we're interested in the limit as
n over T goes to 0 right
and when you have a deal like this what
do you do use that famous rule that we
all mispronounce when we see it written
right we'll use a little L hospitals
rule okay it's l'hopital l'hopital's
rule you have to differentiate the i
guess we differentiate this guy as a
ratio or something and see what happens
when it goes to zero and what we get
when we use l'hopital's rule is that oh
thank god this is still zero so now we
know that we have a point up there and
point down there so now we've got three
points on the curve and we can draw it
goes like that no it doesn't go like
that it's obviously a Gaussian right
because everything in nature is because
you put that laptop away please
everything in nature is a Gaussian so it
looks like this that right no actually
not everything in nature is a Gaussian
and in particular this one is in the
Gaussian either it looks more like a one
of those middle things I used to call
Quonset huts that's what it looks like
Oh like so so that is the curve of
interest now did God say that using this
way of measuring disorder was the best
way no God has not has not has not
indicated any choice here we use this
because it's a convenient mechanism it
seems to make sense but in contrast the
reason it's using information theory
it's not the result of some elegant
mathematics is just a borrowing of
something that seems to work pretty well
any of those curves will work just about
the same because all we're doing with it
is measuring how disordered a set is so
one thing to note here is that in this
situation where we're dealing with two
choices P and n positives and negatives
we get a curve that maxes out at 1 and
notice that it cut it gets up there
pretty fast and
if you're down here at 2/3 and you go up
here this is about 0.9 so quite quite a
bit of the has it gives you a large
number for quite a bit of that area in
the middle so that unfortunately still
doesn't tell us everything we need to
know that tells us how to measure a
disorder in one of these sets but we
want to know how to measure the quality
of the test overall so we need some
mechanism that says okay given that this
test produces three different sets and
we know how to measure the disorder in
each of these sets how do we measure the
quality overall quality of the test well
you could just add up the disorder let's
break that down because that sounds good
so you can say that the thought the
quality of a test is equal to some sum
over the sets produced and what we're
going to do is we're going to add up the
disorder of each of those sets and we're
almost home except that this means that
we're going to give equal weight to a
little branch has almost nothing down it
as we do with a bird we're going to have
a give the same weight to that as a
branch has almost everything going down
so doesn't seem to make sense so one
final flourish is we're going to weight
this sum according to the fraction of
the samples that end up down that branch
so it's as usual easier to write it down
and to say it so we're going to multiply
that times the number of samples and the
set divided by the number of samples
handled by tests
so if half the samples go down to branch
and if that branch has a certain
disorder then we're going to multiply
that disorder times 1/2 all right so now
let's see how it works with our sample
problem well here is our sample data and
we didn't need anything fancy for it but
let's pretend it was a large data set
well let's see what we do we'll go down
this way there are four samples down
that direction that's half of the total
number of samples so whatever we find
down there we're going to multiply by
1/2 this one we're going to multiply by
3/8 and this one we're going to multiply
by 1/8 now what do we actually find at
the bottom of these things well here's a
homogeneous set everything is the same
so if we go to that curve and see what
is the disorder of the homogeneous set
it's zero
let's see they're all the same I guess
that means it's zero over there
so the disorder of this set of three
samples is zero the disorder of this set
of one sample all the same is zero the
disorder of this set well let's see half
of the individuals there half of the
samples there are plus and half or minus
so we go over to our curve and we say
what's the disorder of something with
the equal mixture of pluses and minus
and is and that's one so the disorder of
this guy is 1 so now we've got 1/2 times
1 and 3/8 times 0 1 8 times 0 so the
disorder of this particular the quality
of this particular test as determined by
the disorder of the sets that it
produces is 1/2 0.5 all right let's do
this one so we have 3/8 coming down this
way 5/8 coming down this way 3/8 is
multiplied by the disorder of a set of
uniform things that's disorder 0 so this
guy over here let's see that's
two fifths and three fifths multiplied
you know this is one of those deals
where if you look at the curve you know
you're pretty close to the middle and
that curve goes all the way up to about
0.9 there so you can kind of just look
at this and eyeball it and say well
whatever it is it's going to be the
overall this is this is going to be
something multiplied times five eighths
something like point nine times five
eighths so let's just say the sake of
discussion that's going to be about
point six which is within 100 I think
they're being right just kind of
guessing okay well now we're on a roll
here we have three eighths coming down
this branch three eighths coming down
this branch one quarter coming down this
branch this is zero and this is one of
those deals where these two are about
point nine so it looks like it's going
to be three plus three aces
three-fourths times about 0.9 so that's
going to turn out to be about point
seven
okay so one last go here 3/8 3/8 and 1/4
oh that's that's interesting because
these two are what we got contributed up
to that point seven this one is 0.4
times this is evenly divided so that's
going to have a disorder of a1 so that's
going to be 2.25 bigger than the number
we got over here so that's going to end
up being about zero point nine five so
thanks God our answer is the same as we
got with our simple classroom
measurement of disorder except this is
measuring how disorder stuff is we want
the small number not the big number so
once again based on this analysis you'll
be sure to pick the shadow test because
0.5 is less than 0.6 which is less than
0.7 which is less than point 9 5 so that
accent test is really horrible don't use
it just because somebody has a heavy
accent doesn't mean they're vampire in
fact most vampires have worked very hard
on their accent as I mentioned before
alright so now we know that we're still
going to pick the shadow test as our
first go so that's good now let's see if
we can repeat the exercise with our
second selection the one that we have to
have to pick those guys apart this is
going to be easier because there are
fewer things to work with and there oh
well look that's 0 that's 0 that's 1/2
that's 1/2 so the value so then so the
disorder of this guy is zero point zero
so this is 1/4 1/4 1/2 0 0 1/2 times 1
over at 0.5 that was easy
how about this one oh he says 1 let's
see that's one that's one that's 1/2
that's 1/2 yeah it is 1 so sure enough
the answer also comes out to be the same
as before when we did our just simple
intuition exercise so
no Christopher is this all about using
information theory no no no this is
about this is about see it's not about
the math it's about the intuition and
the intuition is that you want to build
a tree that's as simple as possible you
could build a tree that's as simple as
possible if you look at the data and say
well which which test is the best job of
splitting things up which test does the
best job of building subsets underneath
it that are as homogeneous as possible
so all this information theory all this
entropy stuff is just a convenient
mechanism for doing something that is
intuition 'le sound okay it's not about
information theory it's about a sound
intuition oh by the way does this kind
of stuff ever get used in practice tens
of thousands of times this is a winning
mechanism it's used over and over again
even when the data is numeric how'd it
work if it's numeric data well let's
think about that for a little bit
so let's suppose that you know we have
an opportunity we have where an EMT or
something we work in infirmary what do
they call it these days something else
but anyhow you you work in that kind of
area and you have the opportunity to
take people's temperature and so you've
overt overtime you accumulated some data
on the temperature of people and maybe
you found it there's a vampire here at
about 102 there's a normal person here
about 98.6
but enter and they're scattered around
you know some people have fevers when
they come in so the question is is there
a way of using numerical data things you
can put real not on a real real numbers
so way of using that with this mechanism
the answer is yes you just say is the
temperature greater than or less than
some threshold that gives you a test
just the binary test was like any of
these other tests right yes yeah right
but where do I put the threshold I
suppose I could just put it at the
average value but that might not be the
test the place that does the best job at
splitting the samples into homogeneous
groups Christopher Robin's numerical
analysis
so you tried different places he says
and he's right because this is a
computer this is our slave we don't care
how much it works to figure out the
right threshold so what we do is you say
well maybe the thresholds halfway
between those two guys are halfway
between those two guys or those two guys
are those two guys are those two guys so
we can try one less threshold than we
have samples and we don't care if there
are 10,000 samples because this is a
computer and we don't care if it works
all night that's how you find the
threshold for a numeric test by the way
I asserted earlier on you would never
use the same test twice it's not true
for this yes you would still never use
the same test twice but what you might
do is you might use a different
threshold on the same on the same
measurement the next time around so in
this part having numerical data you may
find yourself using the same the same
test with the same the same axis but
with a different value all right so now
we can say now we have this then we can
go back and compare how this method
would would look when we put it up
against the sort of stuff we were
talking about last time with a with the
electrical covers
so with the electrical covers we had a
situation like this I don't know we had
samples that are places like this and we
had a division of the space that looked
pretty much like that not quite exactly
in the right spots but pretty close so
these are the decision boundaries for
the situation where we are using nearest
neighbors to divide up the data so the
decision boundaries look like if these
were for different kinds of things and
we were using this kind of mechanism and
maybe there may be there's a whole lot
of samples all clustered around places
like that what would the decision
boundaries look like would they be the
same as this god I hope not why because
what we're going to do is we're going to
use a threshold on it on each axis so
therefore the decision boundaries are
going to be parallel to one axis or the
other so we might decide for example
I'll shoot I think I'll draw it again
because it'll get confused if I draw it
over the other one so it looks like this
and that's how darest neighbors does it
but a identification tree approach will
pick a threshold and along one axis or
the other let's say it's this axis it's
only got one choice there so it's going
to put a line there and now what's the
next thing it does well it still has
these two different kinds of things to
separate we're going to assume we've got
four different kinds of things so it's
going to say ah I've come down the
negative side so I need a threshold on
the remaining data and these are the
only two things that are now remaining
so my only choice is fully a threshold
in there now I guarantee this absolutely
guaranteed on the quiz
somebody presumably somebody who doesn't
go to lectures will draw that line all
the way across
and that's desperately wrong because
we've already divided this data set in
half now the choice of what we do over
here is governed only by the remainder
the remaining samples that we see these
two so the threshold is going to go in
there like that
okay so that's what happens when you go
back this is used tens of thousands of
times always used what are the virtues
of it number one you don't use all the
tests you use only the tests that seem
to be doing some useful work for you so
that means that you do a better job
because your measurement technique is
simpler and it cost less because you're
not going to the expense of doing all of
the testing so it's a it's a real winner
but you know what some classes of people
not scientists but I mean people like
doctors and stuff they don't like to
look at these trees they're kind of rule
oriented so they look at a tree like
this for determining what kind of
thyroid disease you have and it would
have maybe twenty or twenty or so tests
in it of various kinds of hormones like
thyroxine and this and that
and they say oh we can't deal with that
so we have to we have to we have to work
with them so what we do is we could hurt
the tree into a set of rules how do we
convert the tree into a set of rules
oops wrong one go away go away oh here's
what I want yeah but how do we convert
this tree into a set of rules it's
straightforward
Christopher what we do you basically
just go down each branch to a leaf so
you say for example here's one rule if
shadow equals question mark and garlic
equals Oh a switch branch where I want
to choose and no doesn't eat garlic no I
think I'll say yes yes
that changes the answer then then if it
eats garlic it's not a vampire right so
that's one of four possible rules
because there are four leaf notes now
almost done we are done except for one
thing we can actually take these four
rules and start thinking behind simplify
them you can ask questions like if I
have a rule that tests both the shadow
and the garlic do I actually need both
of those antecedents and the answer is
in many cases no and particularly in
this case now because if we look at our
data set what we discover is that in the
event that we're talking about a shadow
question mark I guess I had a better
choice the other way
oh no if you look at the garlic all the
garlic's yes yes and yes it turns out
that the answer is no independent of
what the shadow condition is so we can
look at the rules in some cases we'll
discover that our tree is a little bit
more complicated they need to be we can
actually get rid of some of the clauses
so in the end we can help very simple
mechanism based on good old-fashioned
rule based behavior like you saw almost
getting the subject that does the job
and now you're all free to put this
without without any royalty you're all
free to put this into your PDA and use
it protect yourself in the days to come
especially since Halloween is just
around the corner